Joey yeah you don't know what day is
today right Thursday yes it's first day
well done charlie
but what's happening today I really have
no ideas business well there is a chai
today is what about Adam's birthday what
is what about Adam's birthday
what about Adam is 17 today and I cool
yeah I know but what you're actually but
but what's come come man a sec the
countdowns birthday I heard the Ann's
birthday it just thought I was a nice
guy you should be happy for him what the
hell's wrong with you
you don't understand
what do you mean understand I have to
make a video for him okay honey just
calm down a little bit no I will calm
down actually it's birthday it's today
doesn't matter man okay you don't have
to make a video for him you know you
don't understand this is what youtubers
do when it's another YouTube's birthday
they will make a video they don't think
about the video that they were gonna
make make it relevant for that person
you know maybe get some other youtubers
to get getting on a deer as well I can't
do it I am a lot of time Charlie you're
screwed
yes yes I am screwed thank you for that
I don't suppose you have any bad ideas
do you well no I I don't have any good
ideas No then yeah I don't actually
exist do
now I've even lost my alter ego you're a
creative person charlie you can come up
with these things Johnny it's Oh Charlie
yes so Charlie is so good happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday dear happy birthday to you
Charlie
that was the worst birthday video ever
you suck
you
happy birthday Adam